A third model to device
virtualization is the so-called
S0plit-Device Driver Model.
This model is called split,
because all of the device accesses
are controlled in a way that involves
both a component that resides
in the Guest Virtual Machine and
also a component that resides
in the hypervisor layer.
Specifically, devices accesses
are controlled using a device
driver that sits in the Guest VM
called the front-end device driver.
And then the actual driver for
the physical device that is the regular
device driver that's used by operating
systems when they run natively.
In this back-end driver, referred to as
back-end resides in the service VM in
the case where we have a virtualization
model that involves a service VM or
the host operating system in
the case of type two virtualization.
The point is that this
back-end should really be
just the regular device driver
that the service, the Linux OS for
instance and the Service VM would
just be able to install and use,
even if it's not running in
a virtualized environment.
Now although this back-end driver does
not necessarily have to be modified,
the front-end driver has to be modified,
because it explicitly needs to take
the device operations that are made
by the applications in the guest and
then put them together in something that
looks like a, a special message that
will directly be passed to this back-end
component that's in the service VM.
So this approach, essentially applies
only to paravirtualized guests that
will be able to explicitly install
these special front-end device drivers.
What these really are, they look like
wrappers for the actual device API.
So the applications potentially,
they don't have to be modified.
They will continue making the same kinds
of requests for device operations.
But this front-end device driver
will treat these operations,
especially will not attempt to actually
shoot off access to the physical device,
instead will create messages that
will get passed to the service VM.
One benefit of the approach is that
it can eliminate the overheads that
are associated with device simulation
that the previous model required.
Now, we don't have to reverse
engineer exactly what the Guest OS is
trying to do.
The Guest OS via its front
end device driver explicitly
tells the virtualization layer,
so overall these two components.
What exactly is it that
the guest VM requires.
Another more subtle benefit of the
approach is that now that we have this
back-end component that's
centralized in that it will re,
accept requests from all the Guest VM's
in the system and then try to
decide which one of those gets to
execute the physical device access.
There's some opportunities for
some better management of
the shared devices accesses.
So to enforce some finer grained
policies regarding fairness,
regarding priorities and
those sorts of things.